hey everyone black mayor's fourth season
is out on Netflix with more Twilight
Zone style psychological torture for now
warm your heart during these chilly
winter days and to brighten your hopes
for our technological future as we look
ahead at a new year happy new year by
the way we'll all soon be trapped in
simulations right we're gonna be
covering everything the six episodes of
the season which has a reminder USS
Callister Archangel crocodile hang the
DJ metalhead and black Museum we're
gonna review the highs and lows guys
we're gonna offer our personal rankings
compare them to our all-time favorite
episodes of the series we're also gonna
get into some Easter eggs that you might
have missed we got some trivia based on
blackmail we're gonna be covering all
kinds of things as well it's some Star
Wars related news guys welcome to new
rockstars new weekly deep dive into all
the biggest stories this week yes this
by the way this panel discussion show
used to go by a slightly different name
I'd have to realize in a couple other
things online share that title
rebranding oh yeah because she
completely wrecked all of the what is it
any fandom you destroyed it
single-handedly
oh because of our reference but don't
worry despite this little rebranding
that we're going through we're still the
same insightful nerdy occasionally
cringing little arias chat show with the
same insightful nerdy occasionally
cringing little arias hosts like me
Tommy Bechtel I'm Sam I bring the cringe
I'm Phil Molina I bring just water for
everyone I'm bored I thought I brought
the cringe so I guess we're in squid
cringe off too much crunch how the
cringe stole Christmas I know words I
like but I like the guy that's sitting
there like alright let's get
yeah all right well let's get started
sorry where we apologize with our top
story black mayor season poor is now on
Netflix and yeah I already recap the
names of them but just for minding what
happens in each episode a USS CalSTRS
about a shy game developer who traps
clones of his co-workers on a Star Trek
type simulation with him as Captain but
also their plot to mutiny against him
and escape Wow
Archangel was about an overprotective
mother who uses an invasive app to
censor her daughter's perception of the
world and to try to restrain the girls
rebellious behavior with disastrous
results as is always the case
crocodile was about a woman who goes on
a killing spree to cover her tracks in a
world where in a world where memory
reading technology is used by police and
insurance companies hanging the DJ was
the the one light hearted warm episode
and it's about a couple who meet in a
dating app that tells them their
expiration dates or expiry dates but
like many black men I can't tell who's
on which side of me but like many like
me rabbit says yeah it's part of the
deeper conspiracy metalhead is about a
woman on the run from a dog which is one
of the four-legged robots that
relentlessly hunt him ins in the
post-apocalyptic world of this takes
place in did I say dog weird I
definitely said a lot of things weird I
think you're doing a voice thing since I
left oh yeah I'm auditioning to be a
voice actor and just working a lot of
different accents yeah it's good you
should switch a lot between Jamaican
actually that's finally black Museum is
about a roadside museum with exhibits
from past black mayor's stories and with
new short stories about a pain addicted
doctor and a technology that allowed a
coma patients and incapacitated people's
consciousnesses to be inserted into the
minds of other people like along okay
we're gonna talk about all those so
actually spoiler warning if you haven't
seen on the black mirror episodes of
this new season we'll probably give you
a heads up and we're gonna say exactly
what the twist is in the episode we knew
you guys binge day yeah definitely
the day it came out we all watched one
and then I know I had to thought of like
I feel good right now so I'm gonna go to
sleep yeah because it's always the risk
of like you watch a second one and it's
baby murder huh no one had sex with an
animal this time say no yeah that one
barked out of my memory so thank you for
every time someone says I haven't seen
it you know where should I start
yeah well this season what was
everyone's favorite episode you met
unanimously goes without saying that
it's three to one is like you know it's
inoffensive and it makes you feel good
in right a moment that you need it when
you know Netflix makes their series
creators understand the bitching binging
process and so they tell them a lot
about how episodes you know need to play
off of each other and stuff I'm sure you
know that in his head but that you just
needed to hang the DJ moment because
they put you in a hole and then I needed
to give you a lot of to climb at it
which literally happens you know it's
like when you get tortured and then the
one guy brings you like a cookie and
you're like the guy comes back in just
like they're on the same side saying
yeah that's the nice guy don't worry so
so hang the DJ I think is everybody is
like I feel better now so I want to say
this is like the best episode of the
season but I think I know you and I both
had like a visceral reaction to sandra
pero last season and like when you
compare that you're like oh i whipped
that was truly no I drained I was
sitting there and I was like losing so
much fluid just like yes when you're
talking about technology it's so easy to
go bleak and dark and scary that it is
nice to have this one episode that just
does provide some just pure beauty
right I agree and I think that was my
initial reaction to it we actually did
another video that kind of explores hang
the DJ deeper and as I was making that
video I think I have a theory that it's
actually a little bit more bleak and
YouTube era and then Charlie Booker came
out who's like this is the happiest
thing I could possibly write let it be
happy anyways going on Thank You sad
mucus think of it this way if ure
examine this episode if the point of the
simulation was to encourage the two
people to rebel and to escape each other
escape the system with each other do
they truly have free will were they
being programmed and being manipulated
into leaving this cycle that's something
that even Amy says she's like I think
this is the point of the system is that
we leave together it's a test you think
it's like a flawed test because it makes
you want to escape it makes you want to
escape encouragement it doesn't tell you
who you have to escape with well it kept
bringing them back together that seemed
like it was more than a coincidence
right
the simulation that we saw that there
were a thousand of you have to imagine
that it actually ran that with everyone
in their system well I think in this
case this system was purely designed for
Frank and Amy I don't think there was
other couplings that were being tested
it's a it's a dating service so they do
it for everyone who wants to be involved
but in this version of the system system
whatever a it's just these two and then
within this whole universe it's just
being supportive
imagine the system be is Frank being
tested out with Sandra and I'm trying to
be genders Andrew and Frank they only
have success five hundred and sixty-five
times out of a thousand yeah so they're
not as good a match as him and Amy
mm-hmm so I think it actually is like
know whichever one we run it's the one
that gets the nine hundred ninety eight
times that's the only one that we
actually will look similar I think it I
think that's what it is - I think it's
like with like like tinder matches you
guys
ever like just dated through an app it's
like you get paired with people but this
app is like let's see if it actually
would work in like 998 times you wanted
a rebel and I think it goes a little
deeper because you could see that
they're both like punk kids and so it's
like they wanted to rebel they want to
rebuild the system they want to run away
together and they want to fall in love
Romeo and Juliet all that kind of stuff
it's like exactly that an interesting
question is the way to succeed 998 times
that you have to break the system could
it be that like these two lumps on a
hill like both neither ever wants to
break the system 998 times so they're
perfect yeah I think in either case in
that case though only universe those two
simulations know is encouraging them to
rebel so it's like the package that you
should be in love be love hug
Eric a hug last time you had nothing
what is this I've never owned one
speaking of twisting things to see is
there a dark side the USS cast are
ending I think we all kind of were like
hey this is kind of a pretty positive
end but I have to ask that you guys
noticed that Jimmy Simpsons character
was no longer there right at the end so
we last we saw him he went and was gonna
burn exactly already clear eternity what
do we think happened to his character
and it's worth pointing out that you
know you want these characters to
succeed but he actually starts out as a
villain of the episode and in a way
created the whole reason for somebody
else calling fat Damon I'm just blanking
his name but Creed the whole reason to
create the the place to torture people
essentially it's his fault that it
needed to be created of course it's a
kind of victim blaming it's like my
point is more that character maybe
didn't feel like he he needed the same
kind of redemption as everyone else so
I'm wondering what you guys think his
what ended up happening though okay so
he's he's what
obviously the female who was inserted
into the ship last she's a hacker she
really really is good hacker she admired
him she knows how he's worked she knows
coding she's obviously gone in and shut
off the eternal burning yeah and it
seemed like the the way that the lights
were kind of going out on that whole
universe would have included the eternal
burning - Jimmy Simpson actually did an
interview that I read and he's he posed
some theories and he said well really I
I don't like looking at it as a
Redemption arc where you know we have to
think of this guy finally got his
release for all we know like in this
universe he's just atom screaming in
space for eternity and I'm okay with I
think that once they got to the main
like game they could die like this is
like this is free-range they can live
they can die now they don't have to like
keep living this torturous like I'm over
and over again that's why they reset
that's why I like the monster and the
villain got to be normal people again I
think either he got blown out of the
ship and he was flowing around the void
where Jesse died like where his brain
got deleted and so he got to die as well
or he did get to die when the flame went
through and they got through the portal
and he eventually just died on the other
side I think he's gone I think he's yeah
I want I want him to be dead because I
don't want him to be alive and living so
what happened to the simulation or the
second version of him in the workplace
the one that was active day-in day-out
we know all the people they're fine
they're yeah he's unaware of what's
happened he thinks that his CTO just
went comatose all of them will be aware
of what happened like cuz that game got
deleted well here's here's actually
something not to get to I actually don't
like breaking things but here we go and
did you notice that if you know if the
if they're out in the real world now in
the real gaming universe and they're
interacting with you know meth dealers
since that very easily now she could
actually call herself and explain like
hey you know you got a phone call well
first of all hi this is your voice
calling you but also you know how you
got a phone call telling you to go do
that stuff at that apartment that was
because of all of this and she could
tell the whole story yeah to herself and
I would believe myself if I heard my own
voice it's more than you're like wait
that's not how cloning works and then
that's the I'm you
that's not how would you say if you
actually did work yeah what would you
say to yourself to confirm and like that
person believed that it was really you I
would do that man they did a good job I
would do the thing that she did where
it's like well Casey us's Callister was
your favorite episode yeah I thought it
was one of the best feelings that okay
so for me I think that cinema film TV
whatever is a lot about your first
viewing and so I'm not hugely apologetic
about stuff words like well I'm the
second viewing or third view and I'm
kind of like no I think it needed to
work on the first yeah that's the one
we're on the first viewing it put me
through all the things that I wanted
great black mirror up so to do it made
me think about the themes on this play
about you know uh what a man thinks like
you know a woman's purposes but also the
way that we get these these you know
people that snap and they become active
shooters and what I like had all of that
to it it had a really interesting
technological element to it and had a
great twist that I was just like Oh
haven't seen this before and I love
feeling the heaviness before there's a
little continuity error that I was
having trouble with like when she tried
to run away as soon as she appeared she
got teleported back into the the coq10
or whatever he had to take a random jump
ship make it work and then fly after
them at normal speed why couldn't he
just teleport he's godlike he can do
whatever he wants mmm it's a little bit
of a flaw you can literally do anything
what the best example version cuz
because I think is the response would be
like well he programmed it if any of the
people go to the edge they get
teleported back and he did not program
his current things but then he wouldn't
have been able did this move Yeah right
he was doing Star Trek x-men type stop
oh yeah oh that was really hard to watch
by the way when all of her face was
removed I couldn't breathe yeah I
honestly okay so no wonder I was like oh
my god for eternity and then I was like
oh I probably like to be like I get it
like I mean I'd be like I'm gonna stop
trying to breathe I don't need to
breathe anymore yeah this is kind of an
illusion and the whole even drinking
alcohol is an illusion best joke is when
Jimmy pulls on his pants yes
and he had like the best lot like
one-liners and the way he deliver his
monologues yes so and it's so genuine
the way he performs it there was one
other thing that I thought it would be
like full black mirror but as soon as
they got free they're like we're gonna
make it yeah
immediately like they don't want to
trade and Aaron Paul like shoots them in
and episode and it's just like cuz also
it's like what do they do now what you
possibly do in this world like do they
tell people can they get out like what's
the wind but you know what the I think
he might have picked just the more
interesting and it's more interesting to
think about what will they do now then
like oh but you never can win I think
it's it's similar to the story of
paranormal activity when the first film
was made it was an independent film guys
centrally had just been like oh I had
this idea and I made this horror and it
had this really dark ending where
essentially everyone's dead including
the the his wife who gets you know
possessed and Spielberg became involved
in order to do wider distribution Wow
and essentially it was all he did he's
like the movies perfect change the end
not just because it's so dark but
because we need to wonder what's next
for to building Hey it made seven movies
six movies yeah yeah the ending is the
thematically in tune ending like if you
look at the episode no like the if you
look at the episode as a commentary on
like gamer culture and sexism the fact
that they now have to live in a reality
where there's just gonna be a constant
barrage of trolls who were just talking
[ __ ] to them constantly that's kind of
in a way a sort of bleak ending that
they tried to escape from this one guy
imprisoning them in his own like really
terrible fantasy and now they're kind of
still gonna have to deal with these
other types of guys yeah they're just
not still controlling him like a god but
they still have like what if like a kid
just wants to go around start shooting
other ships for no reason because like
people definitely do that were they like
they'll like whatever you're at like a
hundred-and-something levels or whatever
and they nerf e and you're back down -
I'm using all the wrong terms basically
yeah my favorite episode was metalhead
what do you guys favorite favorite yeah
yeah because black and white and I
didn't know I loved it and even
rewatching I loved it even more I I love
the design of the dog I love the synth
yeah I could yeah I begged for that for
like 10 years it doesn't really do
anything doesn't that I was obsessed
with every AIBO generation I never go do
you want to reminded me of though that
first feeling when you are watching
terminator where you're like wow there
is an indestructible thing that is
relentless for yeah that will chase you
to like the extreme ends of the world
yes yeah you watch them get stronger and
stronger almost well this one kind of
has a little bit weaker but like this
girl she is broken women she's broken
she's lost all of her friends the the
mission she's like literally rock bottom
and this thing just keeps coming after
her I love a good western chasing the
way like Mad Max fury road yeah right no
country for old men of this bleak
landscape and there's just one
impossible force and it's just a chase
it's trying to it's cat-and-mouse just
trying to come up with clever ways and
throw off the scent Mad Max is literally
just they drive and they turn around my
question for you I think it's it's a
really great thriller what do you think
it's trying to say about technology okay
so it has that same kind of idea of some
implied backstory right of humans I mean
created to to efficient of weapons that
ended up overtaking them I didn't need
more than that it reminds me of like a
good some of my favorite zombie stories
where there's just a small almost dumb
mission there was a really great episode
of Walking Dead where they go into some
really dumb mission just to get a
picture of Carl's mom back from his
hometown cuz he forgot what she look
like how she looked you know and there's
this episode kind of ends on a similar
note of why would these people go
through that oh there's some things that
are more important than survival the
sustaining human spirit for example
which I know sounds a little done so
you're rolling your eyes right now to me
it totally worked that closing shot
also if you read watch it it wasn't just
the teddy bears they were going after
their words you know they said there
might be other medical supplies other
useful things in that work but teddy
bear was the teddy bear was her goal at
leo was the goal that really was the
goal I thought it was oh I interpreted
it completely differently I thought it
was being welded
yeah medical supplies and it turns out
they got the wrong box anyway I see why
you another way my opinion would be that
it was a teddy bear because that's the
route that's the reason I from the
writing perspective that they were vague
about it anyway was we don't want the
audience to know that what she means is
it's gonna make this child feel better
to have and she said she called it a
replacement which I think he probably
had a teddy bear that was like meant a
lot to him and then maybe one of those
dogs decided a lot of the elements of
the episode were fun the black and white
I was like okay that's kind of feeling
fun like it's very scary like the long
off shot of it running you're just like
this thing won't stop it will never stop
it will keep coming up to the idea of it
picking up a knife to use that as like a
next weapon and just constantly spinning
and getting your mean it's it's just by
the end of it I was like a thing that I
love about black Mir and that could be
that I'm just stuck in what I like about
the show and this episode did not do any
of that at all it's all a way different
story and I just don't think I was in
the right mindset for it what I like
about it is that you show they show us
this new type of technology and where it
could go wrong and how you realize that
people might be worse than that or
something like that like there's like
some kind of like lesson you're playing
around with with this it was just yeah
straight cat and mouse by the end of it
Mouse kills itself and like it's not
I mean classic story but it's just I I
was disappointed that we didn't explore
the dogs more we didn't explore what who
she is or what she's been going through
or what the other people have been going
through how we even got to any of these
like places for these characters I
didn't connect with her I didn't connect
with anything happening just people were
dying and I didn't care by the end of
sounds like you wanted it to just start
earlier yes alright yeah like where it's
like we got you a little puppy for
Christmas it's a robot puppy and then
like it's like but it's mad at me
yeah you know seeing the moment it
happened yeah like I wanted like I
wanted just a little something more to
make me care at all I didn't so I was
bummed yeah yeah I think it back comes
down to the actresses portrayal of the
character to me it like that radio call
and the heartbreak and the weary
exhaustion was relatable enough for me I
loved a store especially compared to
Bachmann when there's so much exposition
you know I liked a bit of a fresh air of
just a story stripped down to its bare
essential parts but that was just me I
get why people maybe didn't like it well
I feel like all we see in a lot of media
now is an onslaught of hope hope and
this one was absolute hopelessness I
think that was all miss Barry yeah I
wish wish I cared more about the
characters for for it to be more
hopeless it was more just like just like
templates it felt like templates of
characters and plot points Sonos you
know what might have done that because I
think I actually I'm okay with not
knowing her backstory everyone not but a
character at the least you have to know
a want for them and the episode told us
if she had the most clear want in the
world right it was get this thing and
take it back to this place right it was
so clear but because they were also
playing the game of we don't know what's
in the box it ended up I think neutering
the feeling that oh what she wants
actually matters hmm so even though they
were so clear about it it also is like
yeah but does it matter what's in the
box that MacGuffin yes before there
could be that I just got caught up on
what's in the box and like that's when I
that's what I wanted from it so sure I
could anybody else have a different
favorite episode that wasn't one of
those black Museum definitely is close
it's a very close to hang the DJ I
really enjoyed it like the the Penn
Jillette writing that opening thing with
the doctor was amazing I was like no
one's a Tori what it was like someone
who was addicted to pain and there are
examples
definitely nobody I thought that was
like just because I was so this is that
shock value it got me like that black
mirror shock value like I enjoyed that
for what it was that intro little
vignette the second vignette not so much
the final one when they wrapped the
background I was like okay we're getting
the Christmas episode three parter and
it brings the background I really
enjoyed that for how they handle that I
liked how they handle it here when they
even mentioned like Santa Junipero a
little bit for a second
a couple other what else oh the hospital
is st. juniper and Santa's yeah we'll
get to the III this one is packed with
[Music]
black Museum for me was the male actor
in that I thought it was I thought yeah
it's just so much character I love like
it was just like crazy man I'm like who
would hire him in a hospital I do is
essentially Ripley right yeah believe it
or not there's aliens through the
showman mmm yeah black Museum it might
have been my Lisa I what's pivot to like
our least favorite no I think that was
my least favorite
I love the pain addicted doctor short
story I like the other short story that
they had and overall the episode just
didn't work for me it felt like they
were trying to replicate the white
Christmas the the Christmas special
really tried to work in a couple
different stories and when they kind of
weave together I started to see it
coming in just the Jon Hamm episode yeah
yeah I loved I loved that one this one
it felt like they're trying to do it in
the same way that they worked in
different short stories that came
together and it just didn't work for me
Canadian I I'm gonna give you my beef
with the doctor storyline it's similar
to what people's beef might be with with
metal head to where it's kind of like
okay followed the idea of the technology
turning on us right then the mirror
turning black I we are at I'm on an
implant that makes him feel what they're
feeling and he gets hooked to the pain
because of the moment of death and it
for some reason like is he's into it
that to me felt like oh this happened to
be implanted into a masochist who felt
pain and enjoyed it that to me is not a
twist of the technology what would have
been a twist of the technology so I
thought it was about to do this was
there's a moment where someone dies and
this is a truth in that at the moment of
death synapses fire at a rate
is it can is incomparable to any other
time in your life and I thought that is
what it was gonna get hooked to where
it's like I cannot experience that
feeling unless the person dies so he'd
get hooked to killing people or poor
people dying but instead it was the pain
that they associated with it it's like
well that's just a human flaw
that's not technology turning around and
biting yeah but it is unleashing a base
to go from within of course that's just
I didn't follow it though like like pain
and pleasure are like close in the brain
and like you can kind of like I got that
like this over stimulation caused him to
his brain to rewire and he started
taking pain as pleasure so I followed
enough but I do like your point of vague
if they kind of fine-tuned it a little
bit and it wasn't just everything it was
killing people yeah it seems like here's
here's the thing with it he could have
stumbled into that problem without the
technology right like you know when you
run your nipple into a door well are
there any other least favorites any
other gras I think arc angel really
missed okay yeah crocodile I think that
was maybe metalhead was just
disappointing crocodile I was like if
you restructured this it could have been
my favorite episode follow just the
insurance agent yeah follow her and like
she's just like following the the marks
and you don't even need to know about
this architect who like went to a murder
and you you turn it into like cut all
that out and it would start with her and
you go through that and she gets to this
house and she this woman is acting weird
and you're like well I have no idea what
the extent of this is and then you think
it's just watching a movie yeah like you
think it's that or you think it's like
maybe she hit some but like it's some
something it's and then once she like
starts to uncover it you get to kind of
explore it but the way the storytelling
could get really interesting is you
watch it through a memory so things
don't always look right maybe colors are
changing in the background like when
they mentioned it so go into that don't
watch it on this little tiny screen like
go into it and memories are fluid like
sure the murders happening but like
maybe the face is changing the bludgeon
inception like yeah it's actually funny
enough memento oh yeah what you want it
to be yeah it would've been really cool
and like you could have her go crazy if
you want but killing the baby I was just
like
like so bleak yeah do you know what it
needed for me it wasn't obvious enough
that she is fearful of the technology
finding her out it just sounded kind of
for me just seemed like it was
snowballing until it was literally a
snowball of death but if you if you're
right if we started with the technology
and the technology was the focal point
and it was this moment where she was
like all right I've done it oh my gosh
there was a witness and it's a baby but
this technology will be able to like for
me it just seemed like well I've killed
everyone else and for me it was like
well she's a mom and now she's realizing
this baby you know maybe left there for
a little bit too long so it was almost
with mercy that she ended her life but
it wasn't about the technology for it to
be you know I like that choice made yeah
I get that you know it's crazy to me is
that I as the gerbil moment is happening
I was like in my like the front of my
brain I was kind of like the gerbil and
then like the rest of my brain was like
I love it that that's what brought her
down that felt like black mirror to me
it's like you cannot predict the extent
to which the technology is gonna get I
just didn't buy her going this crazy I
know that's what they said her up to be
but I'm just like what are you doing yes
what are you doing at this point like
you think you're getting away it's like
no now you're just doing it cuz like it
that's what I mean yeah and an arc angel
I felt like they kind of missed the mark
a little bit like wouldn't it have been
more interesting if she stayed like
blind to like a lot of the like like
harder things in life and as an adult we
need to watch this
don't actress instead of a 25 year old
playing a fifteen year old like like
having sex and like doing cocaine and
then like the craziest part that's like
what is happening is the mom clearly
downloads the memory of this of her 15
year old daughter having sex with an
older guy then editing it on her
computer and then downloading it to her
phone and bringing it into the store
because you couldn't she had you watched
her transfer it to the computer and then
she brought her phone in so she clearly
went to like so many steps of watching
your daughter have sex and I'm like what
is happening it's gotta be the future
Sam probably actually did happen there's
ammo
where you I did like that charging
moment I was like that's there's a
moment that sounds like the episode
probably really worked for you then it's
as a little girl when she's seen her
grandpa died and she can't see it yeah
it's just like you're kind of saying
like if we had followed that to its
conclusion of like what would happen if
you were never exposed to anything
negative but it's like I'm gonna be like
playing on your gut instinct with fear
so it's like if she never saw the dog
and doesn't understand like that kind of
fear if someone goes to mug her and goes
to attack her and ends up killing her
and she's got no idea because it's just
a blur I can't defend yourself against
something that you can't see her
acknowledge like right like what if you
wrote a character that got hit by a car
and now she's paralyzed could she even
see the pain that was causing like in
her own brain the stress of like seeing
that now she cannot walk like she
doesn't have that freedom anymore could
you see herself yeah like what if you
went further with that instead we went
with mom going crazy and I don't think
we went far enough for like crazy mom
enough did she I kind of got the
impression that she wanted to grow up
quite quickly because of this guy
showing her YouTube videos when she was
young like as soon as she got the
parental guidance flicked off this guy
was like oh you can't you can see things
now look at this video of this guy dying
look at this video of porn and that's
when she you know has sex the first time
and he's like you don't need to do that
and she said well that's all I've seen
so that's what I know that what that is
like with we're learning from the
Internet and applying it to life well I
mean it is definitely commentary on
helicopter parenting and how it doesn't
actually work when I used to tutor kids
a lot and and they were so foul-mouthed
and such bad kids when they were there
at the tutoring center but they were
hiding that so much from their very
affluent parents so that is kind of
think what the episode is about is like
you can try to remove all these things
because they're kind of gonna get a
worst version of it yeah and like learn
like the darkest versions well we'll
continue to talk about black Menace
episodes right now let's move on to this
week's trivia question we're gonna keep
things black mirror theme
okay here we go okay in the black mirror
Christmas special white Christmas 2014
what was the radio song that repeated at
the end of the episode when the
consciousness of Potter was trapped in
the simulated cabin a thousand years per
minute poof and if any of us are able to
get it a bonus tiebreaker
and if Potter was left in there for two
weeks of a Christmas break how many
years would have transpired within that
imprisonment so I guess it's just a math
one a thousand years per minute wait a
minute wait two weeks yeah two weeks 14
days will reveal the answer at the end
of this episode as always the winner
will get to you know do that crazy thing
where and the winner has decided by our
judges because I don't think any of us
will probably get this they'll get to do
our sign-off advice at the end of the
video and they can do it whatever a
crazy voice or a new character they're
trying out meanwhile the loser will have
to read our in other news wrap-up
headlines and be hilarious on the spot
and cleverly riff on it and whatnot
reveal that later everyone got their
answers locked in great strum stop for
me this year we here at new rock stars
are obviously obsessed with black mirror
and like many of you are paranoid
watchful eyes led us to spot a number of
Easter eggs referencing past episodes in
season four now if you think about it
these Easter eggs actually some of them
have some super interesting implications
for the extended universe at the Black
Mirror world
so let's break them all down and I'm
gonna just list through these and fly
through them but go boy we're gonna
actually for all of you watching we're
gonna re-edit these we edit this segment
in a separate video later so you can get
a closer look at where each of these
things are okay let's start with the
Easter eggs that we spotted in USS
Callister many of you spotted the boys
cameo by Aaron Paul Jesse Plemons no
star no I was so cool he was the voice
in the final scene the anonymous gamer
who talks [ __ ] to the crew there was an
even sneakier cameo from Kirsten Dunst
that's plenty to his real-life fiance he
passed her she passed by him in the
office in the background Wow yeah it's
not crazy
yeah I didn't I didn't catch it at all
the Kirsten Kirsten - sneaky sneaky the
receptionist uses the same
dating app that the guy used in play
test in season 3 that's the haunted
house episode remember he hooked up with
a girl in the on the big nap the DNA
scanner device from Jessica limits
character was made by TCK our systems
it's the same company that made the
afterlife software in the Sanjana Poirot
episode last season they show up a
couple times yes and then two of the
planets from USS Callister ranek be in
skill aim for those are the names of the
killers in white bear all season 2
that's very and then daily drinks from a
brand of milk called Ryman or Raymond
which is a nod to Raymond and men
against fire last season the soldier
episode she mentioned actually that her
family owned a farm which is kind of fun
ok moving on quickly to Archangel
episode 2 when the mom is considering
the program at the beginning the demo
shows the troubling imagery of a soldier
firing a gun which is from an against
fire that's actual footage I definitely
caught that one teenage Sara's bedroom
there's a poster for her tusks that
wasn't named of the wrapper and hated
abomination who was one of the targets
at some point as well as a poster for
harlech shadow that's the game that's
scary game from a test so I guess that
game exists in this world now I want to
move on quickly to crocodile had some of
the most interesting Easter eggs and I
have a big question for ya yeah there's
some crazy stuff that happens here ok
well first just to get out of the way
there's this episode reuses
Emma Thomas's anyone who knows what love
is will understand you know you can
blame me yes so great that was also in
15 million merits and white Christmas
and men against fire it's kind of like
they use it every season no it's not
some crazy stuff here when Mia flips
through the hotel movie category is kind
of like their version of Netflix the
classics option shows a robotic Beyond a
flower it's the actual thumbnail from
hated in the nation so she's like able
to watch that story in her was fun but
then within the the porn options if
she's flipping through one it's called
best of wrath babe babes that was the
porn that the girl ended up doing in
15,000,000 marriage
and the hotel clerk at that hotel
references a tabloid story about the
host of hot shot which was the the name
of the American Idol America's Got
Talent Britain's captive show reality
contest show from that episode so all
right let's pause here just overthink
this because the implication is that the
world of 15 million merits the one with
the stationary bike peddlers underground
Dania is the same world at the surface
would have crocodile so yeah I think
it's safe to assume but Mia's world is
powered by those poor people down below
maybe even that smokestack that she
shoved the body of her ex-boyfriend down
was like exhaust from that underground
power plant which is what I was thinking
that I don't know necessarily exactly
it's that power plant but that there is
a place where this thing is real right
and it's providing energy but what
throws it off for me is when you see the
graphic novel comic of 15 million merits
that he's reading in the lighter episode
and it's like so that's all that also
would just be a story unless they did
the meanest thing in the world with like
hey you know we have slaves on there
let's make him into a comic those
stories into comic books oh are you
saying that the world in 50 million
merits is like bigger than just that one
little place because when he goes up to
okay good it's like when he goes up to
the top floor he sees a lush forest
right or is that projection simulations
like who was watching their show right
people at home so there must be like
normal people out there right is that I
don't know why that makes it even
bleaker you know they get out but let us
know we sent downstairs to cycle who's
right in the nation was just a story
within that world that like that's the
media they watch is this world where
bees could be used as fillers assassins
anyway it's crazy to think okay but
getting back to some of these Easter
eggs in crocodile Mia Birds an article
from UK in online that's a news agency
from the very first
episode was national anthem
the pizza truck that the guy gets hit by
his fences pizza that's the same place
that just Clements orders pizza from in
u.s. Callister but i guess now it's
evolved into automated delivery trucks
even though crocodile is my least
favorite episode I love that pizza was
delivered that way you know to make it a
little joke it's going out it's real
cool and then finally this is probably
one of the teasing missed Easter eggs if
you look at the close-up of the printout
you have to pause it one of the
paragraphs at the bottom of the article
says quote of course the real question
is why anyone would pause on what
they're watching just to read a sentence
and a printed out newspaper article says
a voice in your head before advising you
to go and share this finding on reddit
was making fun of it's exactly what
happened
[Music]
hang the DJ there wasn't a whole lot of
Easter eggs the dating app that we see
is the same one that I mentioned before
I guess there's one dating app in this
universe and that's now we know how it
works in the simulated copies of you in
metal head when Maxine goes through the
drawer there's actually a postcard from
a place called San Junipero which is
pretty fun actually if you think about
it because in that play test episode
it's like time gets extended over and
over again and like all those weird like
Russian nesting dolls of like the worlds
that he's like dying in over and over
again so it's like I can't make sense
all that time is extended out and said
yeah it's all invented by the same
company TCK are which shows up in the
metal head as well it's on the side of a
truck but it also looks like Callister
the the USS Callister that also could be
the name of a company because it's
written on than on the name of the
analog screen inside the truck that the
guy's trying to hack into at the
beginning that is a Callister equipment
so we'll see maybe these are just names
of everything that uh that they use ok
black Museum of course packed with every
kind yeah it truly was so just to point
out everything we spotted the gas
station it's called BRB connect like be
right back
be right back was the name of the first
episode of season 2 with where the guy
gets all that BRB is known for yes
couldn't say everything else it's like
Rose Museum there's a video screen
showing Victoria from white bear and a
newsreel
that shows p.m. callo Mary's Pig
reference to the first episode we see
Mary it he was good enough to marry it
as well
shotgun wedding yeah the exhibits
include Carlton blooms hanging from that
episode Carlton bloom was the
experimental artist who orchestrated
whole thing there was also a mannequin
of the man with a gun who chased
Victoria and white there in that weird
white pattern on his ski mask there was
a copy of harlech shadow game from play
test there was one of the bees from
hated in the nation there was Tommy's
lollipop and ironmans milk and the DNA
scanner from USS Callister I know that's
annoying a lot of people because didn't
I rescue the lollipop from the fridge
all right maybe I'll put it back into it
she grabbed it right yeah so there's no
way that anyone should really I'll say
all kind of it's a river like a
recreation of it well I'll kind of by
that the way that that character was
played a lot of these things probably
aren't legit yeah it's yeah there's also
the shattered tablet screen from
Archangel we got a good close-up of that
and the bloody bathtub from crocodile
yeah and even though this is weird
because they said all the things were
like crime-related
there were the dresses worn by Yorkie
and Kelly in San Junipero like the
dresses in seem like an EVE crimes were
going on in that episode but whatever so
they got the fake dresses out of the
right maybe they were based on these who
knows and then meanwhile within those
flashback stories
Rollo's lab rats were named Kenny and
Hector those are the names of the
experimental lab rat characters and shut
up and dance that was a you know the
webcam blackmailers own the hospital you
mentioned this before over that role of
work that was called st. junipers which
may have inspired Rollo to call his
virtual paradise an Junipero when he
went on to work for a TC TC KR and then
yeah you also mentioned this the graphic
novel that he reads is the story of 15
million merits now to me in black mirror
black Museum the seen this episode
connects pretty much all the episodes
prior made me think that this could be
like one own meta dimension where Rolo
is like kind of a devil figure he's
profiting from all these all the world's
technological evils simple simple things
without it is is that no no but that's
it kind of seems like that idea of like
coming to my shop and I have alright oh
yeah need need need full things
yeah and Rick and Morty is it well it's
a Stephen King so everybody's made fun
of that yeah yeah I don't know I kind of
liked that idea and some people were
saying that some of the other exhibits
in the background might have been like
future episodes that we haven't seen yet
I'd be very clever are we gonna get
another season will be one yeah no I
that mean I like the theory it's a fun
one Rollo definitely has the charisma of
like a double character he's yeah I
liked hearing him speak he did speak a
lot throughout that entire episode would
have liked to hear the female lead like
a little more I didn't like her a lot I
wonder if her accent couldn't hold up
over time or something but that's the
thing it's like it kind of wrecked the
twist because she's like are you
wondering why my accent changed I'm like
your accent when did it
like I said nine words okay well those
are all the things that we were able to
spot and black mare we'd love to you
know go through and rewatch and find all
the other connections because black
mirrors just laid in with Easter eggs
but let us know what other because we
did a breakdown of hanging the DJ let's
know if there's any other questions you
have about this that you'd want to see
us take on in a video and let us know if
you have any shared universe series of
exactly how the black mare universe work
beat for beat okay let's move on to
another interesting story that came up
recently one that we'll look at by the
numbers now the number I am interested
in is 1.1 billion whoo that is how many
dollars Star Wars the last Jedi has made
in the three weeks of screening in
theaters worldwide it was the most
profitable movie of 2017 it's running
just behind the force awakens just fine
the reason I bring this up guys is
despite this huge success the audience
reaction was a bit more mixed and in the
days following the movie's release some
geniuses began to point fingers to
explain some reasons behind this
disappointment take The Hollywood
Reporter for example who last month
Miller with it fan theories on YouTube
calling new rockstars out by a name and
just to quote them here's what they said
about so we actually have the article up
that we can show on the screen behind us
the channel warns every time that
they're not yeah yeah the channel warns
every time there may be spoilers because
they make guesses as to what will happen
in the film based off the trailer in
previous films if they guess right any
surprise is ruined if they guess wrong
and their guests was well-received by
the viewer there is disappointment when
the
film doesn't deliver seems like a no-win
situation which would likely result in a
disappointing movie going experience new
rock stars ruin rocks ruin rock stars
right okay it would have been 1.2
billion I have my own thoughts on this
I'll let you guys think and you know
maybe we can take this criticism like is
there it does any great responsibility
come with our great predicting power
well real quick I'll say that's not what
people had issues with what Star Wars
yeah it wasn't like oh new rocks are
just theory about you saying that people
shouldn't talk about movies before they
come out and think about how they could
possibly go and he's like you know you
should see the trailer turn your brain
off wait months sit down and watch you
don't want any anything to do with it
you want to go and completely pure and
clean and make your own mind up well you
want to explore every single option it
happened and that person probably don't
want to go up here and clean didn't go
watching new rock stars video spoiled
I'll say you got to remember also our
boy JJ Abrams set up a lot of questions
that felt like they would have huge
answers so I would kind of talk to those
two directors but like it feels like
this handoff didn't exactly go with the
Brawn perfectly the best no it's I I
laugh at this cuz I think if you were if
you guys watch all of our Star Wars
videos most of our predictions didn't
really cover the things that people were
griping about like raised parentage and
Luke's past relationship with kylo I
mean we touched mine but like we don't
make any big bold predictions that we
were either excited we didn't raise any
expectation post on kylo ren's hairstyle
my biggest craziest predictions where
Luke Skywalker has amnesia and and and
that kylo Ren ignited the lightsaber
which I didn't come with that theory
just you know regurgitate that kylo Ren
ignited the night lightsaber not Han
which if those were true people would
have been super pissed I don't think
anyone really took this seriously
you didn't predict the nipples kylo
ren's [ __ ] let's see how did I you can
see that coming from miles away yes
now especially that weird CEO thing that
Luke's just blue milk work Sam not out
of work how do you think you get normal
milk so here's here's the thing though
even though we're being pretty defensive
right now I actually will say and I'm
gonna totally throw myself out there
diving in too deep into films can ruin
the twist when they do happen that I
actually think is a valid point of all
specifically talk about a feeling I had
in Game of Thrones not this past season
but the season before I thought it was
masterful the way that the if we come up
with a name for it the Sept explosion
the greens like that that it was being
foreshadowed the whole season long
including the way that the fire would
travel and even the color green a lot of
these things were there and I didn't
want to necessarily catch that but I
couldn't help it and so I felt like for
like four episodes or something I was
like this stuff is gonna blow and I feel
like it was so amazing that it still hit
you know it pretty high on my meter of
excitement and and like the wow factor
at the moment but I do got a wonder what
if I hadn't seen that coming right and I
think that's I I totally agreed and that
happened with the wall coming down and
Game of Thrones last season I think if
you can go down too far that rabbit hole
if you start trying to predict
everything that happens in the story and
I think that's we've had this
conversation before we're doing
breakdowns like how much do we want to
lay out the exact what we think the plot
structure will be seem to seem do people
really care about that they kind of
wanted that when they go see the movie
but I think it's more fun with our
videos and we just go into really
out-there theories what is some what-if
scenarios or it's you know the point of
a fan theories say there's some loose
evidence and when you connect it kind of
presents an interesting possibility that
probably isn't true yeah it's worth
noting people don't know this that there
have been times where we've had
discussions and we've decided let's not
bring this one up
if it's true it or we'll just have ruin
people's experience of this so we just
leave that out I mean you have to also
have credit for those moments where
you're like guys guys what about and
then you get to relay that what-if
moment which does make sense and minds
are blown like that it's a really
rewarding dependent with the ball coming
down I think before see right up you're
seeing six ended I said I think seen
seven final shots can be the wall coming
down and I like took all credit for it
and when we did our season eight
predictions but then I'm like bull here
all the other things they're predicted
that world is gonna die so I think yeah
and it's and it's you know that's the
the curse of being an attentive viewer
right like I got we got a lot of credit
for predicting that doomsday would be
and Batman V Superman like from the very
first trailer was like I think that's
gonna be doomsday I think it's gonna be
they brought back whatever and people
are like wow you you totally predicted
that and it's like honestly like they
kind of want you to start thinking about
those things by the way they cut the
trailer yeah you know I I agree that
like I I definitely would go down rabbit
holes and I got I want to read up on
like what's gonna happen I think I've
learned my lesson with Avengers age of
Ultron cuz I was like I want to like I'm
so excited that movie was it really let
me down and I was really excited about
it
but I learned really early on the
Quicksilver is gonna die like people
like we're like predicting all this
stuff and I'm like you know I shouldn't
have read that like I now know like a
limit of how far do which ones I want to
read but also that's not on them for
making that right that guess it's on me
Roxton you guys know it's on me for
reading it so while there you go there
are truths here but also people make
choices to watch these kinds and things
and join in the conversation this is
exactly what Disney once liked this
whole conversation is we're we're part
of the game they can rule the luhan's
what we're gonna do with these trailers
when they release yeah they they know
they want people to talk about they want
the fans to break it apart because they
know people have choices that they don't
want to know anything they don't have to
watch our videos and one final thing
I'll add is that what we try to do is we
try to enhance the joy that you feel
when you're discussing these properties
and give you more fodder to get excited
about and get giddy about and The
Hollywood Reporter has some of that and
it has a lot of things that are like
specifically meant to make people feel
bad about Hollywood and the things that
people love a lot and I think like you
know you should in fact even us trying
this feel a little bad about something
that's like if your business is and
trying to make people feel bad or feel
good I'm gonna pick the feel-good fun
I'm sorry especially if one of them is
representing where things are going in
the future and one is a dying medium
that was just trying to point the finger
at millennial yeah I did it I called it
a journalism major what have a website
alright let's move on guys to our need
to know lightning round some questions
I'm gonna fire them at my co-host who
have to answer them as quickly without
hesitation hell yeah are we ready mm-hmm
hey at the awesome iron p asks what was
the first nerdy thing you got really
into and passionate about oh my goodness
computer games on an ms-dos system the
five 1991-92 yeah the Wolfenstein was a
little bit after that weren't you like
negative six I was definitely not
bowling samo
or good buddy mama would you want the
force or the Infinity Gauntlet yes
exactly I could make any world I want I
could do whatever I want with that I can
control you brain and he saw any reality
any space and any time you couldn't go
get the force if you have the infidel
that's true you can cross reality's
cross cinematic universes that seemed
kind of win an argument
use your words
so Kramer 13a sue this is toughy what's
the motto for 2018 you rock says news ya
feel good about the things you like and
share them with more people no nipples
caught in doorway yes that's it well are
you trying to ruin my 2018
no but it wouldn't what I mean by that
is like there's been a lot of like
people I there's a lot of like shame
about the thing you like like did you
like this new Star Wars you did you're
an idiot yeah yeah let people like what
they like and if there's something you
like tell other people about it this fun
to share that's agreed okay and for me
at Carroll BDC Deva asks what was your
favorite music from Game of Thrones the
last Jedi and Justice League and why
that's a multi-part question okay you
can't be surprised when this is in your
hand no you use the door handle Carroll
BBC TV okay so Game of Thrones light of
the seven I think yeah this season six
finale we did a whole breakdown of that
it was a good job with that uh the last
Jedi let's see I love it's from specific
last read I just love John Williams kylo
Ren theme I think it's amazing and yeah
so I just love how like you feel his
sense of loss and his innocence being
taken away and in light of the seven I
just love how piano was used as the
first game of throat something they used
modern instrument and then for Justice
League I love Danny Elfman's theme for
the flash it had this like cool kind of
like thank you for all of you for
submitting your lightning round
questions keep an eye out for our tweet
next time if you want to submit your
question to us but now comes the time
for a 15-second shout-out where each of
us is 15 seconds a shout-out plug or Ram
about anything we want I say Sam when we
start we always start with mine geez I'm
trying to watch Grey's Anatomy from the
very beginning because I hate myself
there are 14 seasons of that show I'm 23
episodes for 14 seasons of Grey's
Anatomy and so Shonda Rhimes who's a hit
maker she has
and Grey's Anatomy is still the top show
Wow you know what shout out to Skyrim
I'm playing the updated edition in 4k on
Xbox one and I would have sunk about 50
hours into it over a week's break but
that's cool right good oh man mines
gonna be so dorky but I didn't pre-plan
one so it's just what I've been up to
lately I shout out to bigger pockets
calm it's uh it'll teach you about real
estate investing it's fun oh yeah my 15
seconds out out is on New Year's Eve
deadmau5 to the DEA did a concert where
Rick and Morty came and crashed it on
the big screens and they diffused what
they thought was a bomb that was just a
countdown and it was super fun and go
find it on YouTube it's super funny it
was only for that audience and now us
happy on sci-fi starring Chris Maloney
I'm doing it again because I said the
show we I don't know why people or not
I'm excited about the show it's a Patton
Oswalt christopher meloni he is a hit
man that's like an alcoholic and he's
just disgusting he's a horrible person
but he's travel an imaginary friend of a
little girl who got kidnapped is trying
to get him to go find the girl but the
the imaginary friend is played by Patton
Oswalt me and it has the mind of a child
so I can't like figure out and so it
can't figure out I can't remember where
the girl is and like the imaginary
friend has to see all these violent
things happen like it just you see its
innocence going away throughout the show
it's so funny if you like violence go
check it out what's it on Syfy it's a
dream he had a teen girls would be more
happy so here's this let's finally
return to the trivia question that we
asked earlier this great black mirror
think I did pretty good everybody
okay so just for any guys of the
question the black mayor Christmas
special white Christmas what was a radio
song that repeated at the end of the
episode when the conscience of the
Potter was trapped in the simulated
cabin for a thousand years per minute
and then how many years would that be in
his time for a bonus Sam thinks the song
is have yourself a merry little
Christmas
i Eric thinks that the song that plays
is the Alvin and the Chipmunks version
of the hula hoop Xmas song thousand
years in a minute of that yeah yeah
Maude says I'm dreaming of a white
Christmas and then oh and then sorry and
then Philip wrote Bing Crosby I'm
dreaming of a white Christmas as well or
darude sandstrom sir is I wish it could
be Christmas everyday by wizard well oh
I thought that song was by Horatio Sanz
it's some Christmas song oh and by the
way the amount of years I would have
transpired in this thing's is 2 million
Eric thinks it's 5 million Maude says
don't make me Maps is 20 million 160
thousand years that's like a Cretaceous
period or height like that's super yes
yeah 20 million years it doesn't make it
easier to understand resign just like
the Cretaceous crocodile crocodile
yes google it okay well the winner who I
think I'm dreaming of a white Christmas
might be closest so then what either was
to close on math neither of us did the
math and then the loser
well I write I wrote two million and and
then and well you said the winner will
do our good-byes our winners in this
case and you can make fun of our names
the Twitter hounds you can do whatever
team up voice character you want to do
and then I'm gonna have to do the in
other news headlines that we didn't have
time for I'm gonna have to read them at
the end of each headline I'm gonna have
to make a joke right oh wow here here I
go okay Kendrick Lamar is producing an
out producing the album for Black
Panther and he released the single all
the stars this week meanwhile a
regardless of how good the movie is all
the stars will probably sing praises of
this movie so that they're on the right
side of history but I think thrown in
Rick and Morty each confirm this week
that their next seasons will not air
until 2019 but that won't stop new rock
stars for ruining these four fans ok
Netflix Netflix will no longer be
streaming all the seasons of lost the
rights to which have now transferred
over to Hulu yeah well I think that
it'll be on the people of Hulu to be
disappointed and confused by the missed
opportunity wow that whole thing was
just lost ok Hulu also announced that is
renewing 90s animated series the
Animaniacs for two new seasons well
because we're so creatively bankrupt
that only by looking backwards can we
move forwards in this industry that's
not funny that's just true and then
after a man under the influence of
painkillers from his who is 20th surgery
went viral for freaking out of her
missing Deadpool to Ryan Reynolds has
invited them to
the movie's premiere my Reynolds is like
the best guy in the world
yeah make fun of them maybe hurt 41
there you go Ryan Reynolds look closer
to death
painkillers and do it a nice thing for a
fan there's nothing to make fun of
believe he doesn't turn out to be that
racist kid from all right yeah yeah a
little bit pretty poor job I need to
start winning more all right you guys
take a weird goodbye
yeah thank you guys for watching this
week's episode of what's her name Fox
and price knew the Newsies and their
rocks
there you go I want to thank our host a
grown baby
no I'm talking about them sham and good
Eric Voss more like thank you Eric lost
and the real burn is that she did not
say and then there's Philip Molina who's
back which is absolutely wonderful to
have you at the table again and welcome
to a new year 2018 yay let's say thank
you thanks it is exciting to be back
I've missed Tommy and then of course we
have the lovely at Maude Garrett who is
just like a like knight in shining armor
and I think that you should be a lot
nicer to Maude I in the comments I can't
take it of course you can but spread the
love some of you are a team just be nice
yeah like the things you like and then
otherwise okay yeah thank you guys and
comment down below tweet us at new rock
stars like this video share it around
and subscribe to narc starts for deep
dives in occasional ruins movie going to
experiences of all the stuff that you
love guys thank you for joining us
Happy New Year see you next week bye bye